I'll be talking back that the comedian
that and then like one restroom so you
have to wait for Gabriel lessieur to use
it so you know he blow that up oh yeah
it's funny like as big as he was he
never broke a toilet on the road I did
really just sitting on it yeah we were
we're in Oxnard you know when you have
to go there fast you put on your pants
and like I have a problem I never sat
down slowly on a toilet
I used to have a unified school district
school toilets at the housing project
toilets uh-huh so what I said it was
like this was a hotel toilet so my room
was on top no my room was on on top
right so I used that toilet and then
like Oh water came out so I went
downstairs to Gabriel s bathroom what's
going on I don't know man I think that
toilets broken man you go check the coat
check it out there's water everywhere
huh so much
[Music]
[Music]
all right well here we go he's fixing
his shirt fixing his hair all right hot
breath averse welcome back to the hot
breath podcast
I'm your host Joel buyers and today's
guest is the true definition of a
survivor in this world born in Mexico
immigrant here to America after three
attempts to cross the border he lands in
the hoods of Boyle Heights a kid with a
speech impediment that now became a
comedian is pretty hilarious but his
journey here is not hilarious where he
started selling merch at LA Dodgers
games to then selling crack as a teen
dad after a stint in rehab he then jumps
headfirst into stand-up comedy and the
world is so much more greater for it he
won Last Comic Standing fun side note
about that even though he want 250,000
most of that went to his baby mama for
child support but just to show this
man's true character he was still
willing to donate a lot of that money
that he had left back to his
neighborhood so this guy his success
does not come without a warm heart and
he is not only had showtime specials HBO
specials
he has Netflix show he has his own
podcast what's up fool and now he is on
the one and only hot breath podcast
bienvenidos
how are you good man how are you I'm
doing great thank you for taking the
time to do this this is uh I gotta say
in researching you and you and miss Pat
are proud like your stories like I had
miss Pat on here and I was like all
right her story is like whoa and then
diving into your story I'm like how is
he alive and how did even how is he so
not only alive but how are you so nice
as well you know do you ever ask
yourself that
no when you have miss Pat I don't know I
saw a story of her when she said that um
she was stealing money off the camera
Shuster and President Jimmy Carter came
in yeah McDonald's Wow yeah yeah yeah
yeah
she was like a 16 she was young so think
she had two kids by the time she was a
teenager
she's been shot several times I mean
you've been beat up several times and
you survived I got beat it was my fault
I started in the fight I never got beat
up because someone was looking for me or
mhm
a random beatdown or so I deserved it
but you you weren't more of a cash
register you're more of a shoplifter I
guess is that more was that more your
scheme not really like a big shop now
I'm not really a shoplifter I got caught
once in seventh grade and I quit Oh
daddy yeah I was not good I was stupid
my friend he made like a birdcage a box
and woodshop mm-hmm and we were putting
a candy you need and walking out and
then one day I decided to put a pack of
sneakers in my folder and it got got
what happened they just said okay like
six fat Snickers oh I got greedy yeah
yeah would you I was sitting M&Ms
everyday I mean they're walking in ice
I take the family pack of M&Ms every day
do you still do that anymore
no okay not anymore like I not even but
like I get more most austere criminals
who anybody like who has stolen stuff or
thought about a night I was there with
my wife and Saget
Saginaw no there's no Swiss a Swiss
little town in California in which be
past Santa Barbara in an hour north it's
called soul bang okay switched oh it's a
little one mile what a half mile town
and it's all Swiss at the Swiss Alps I
love Swiss people there a lot of Swiss
doors but it's all decorated like
Christmas so it's all lit up like a
winter home even in the summer my wife
and I walking around and I I for some
reason I just turn it over the door it's
open
mm-hmm
it is open one of these doors then I
thought why I I locked it from the
inside I locked it so nobody else to
open it but then I keep walking and
Eileen works like kissing Eileen to a
door and I was like wow I could break
you to every place in here right now
that's where your mind goes yeah because
I'm leaning back and I hear the door
like barely like my weight that's it
this was your test like a bait
neighborhood that's why I didn't know
you liked bait car what are you going
yeah yeah yeah yeah and you're making
out with your wife and this is happening
is that what you say yeah just in a door
like you go into a dark room and you're
making out with your right side Oh
Christmas time oh that's lovely there
was Christmas trees lit up outside the
neighborhood and inside the neighborhood
it was good and your mind you're making
out with your wife and then your mind
immediately goes to oh I could just
robbed this place
yeah yeah do you have to fight those
urges no I didn't know if it's like
ingrained I was younger and I'm
successful maybe but I don't know have
you ever been on a road with other
carmakers mm-hmm there's always a
shoplifter with you or there's always
someone on a car that wants to eat
healthy mm-hmm I don't understand nobody
in the group that what's reality mm-hmm
so after a while just eating power bars
oh yeah then he go and he started
robbing stealing power bars mm-hmm I
actually did my first little tour I did
I was a hotel minibar attendant and my
job was to clean out the expired food so
I just kept collecting all the expired
Clif bars so we went on this week-long
tour and I just say Clif bars the entire
time oh man have you done anything like
that out on the road like just crazy
like besides I mean destroying hotel
rooms and things like that oh no way
working in El Paso the headliner after
radio they took him to a a breakfast
place and um Texas cause the taquitos
they call everything taquitos okay it'll
be a flour tortilla they call it turkey
okay so they're not there's no such
thing as a burrito like in Texas there's
burritos but most of the tex-mex
restaurant don't call it but really call
it taquitos but their Houston ain't no
password no little rather being on
breakfast burritos for some reason and
that's something different from where I
grew up you know laying this only one
delicious breakfast burrito
and it's called Rick's burgers rigs
burger it's a chain but if you go to
Rick's they got a badass but sin heads
so like aroused almost like we're
talking out of like a female little blue
like tacos and burritos large with tears
and we tell you man the whole grill is
breakfast tacos mmm we're talking about
ham and eggs having egg and cheese
potato and eggs chorizo and egg machaca
I made everything and so the headline he
buys 30 of them in her legs I love we
buy more than 30 cursed or something
so we eat them all I end up to em I
ended up after telling one of the comic
you know what man I'm tired party
[Laughter]
everybody else I mean that burrito gave
us so much gas and you're trapped in a
car chapter don't know let me tell you
back the comedian there and they're like
one restroom so you have to wait for
Gabriel Esther to use it so you know he
blow that up oh yeah it's funny like as
big as he was he never broke a toilet on
the road I did really just sitting on it
yeah we're in Oxnard
you know when you have to go real fast
Ford underpass and like I have a problem
I mean I've never sat down slowly on a
toilet
okay bye mr. dog howl a unified school
district school toilets at the housing
project toilets uh-huh so what I said it
was like this was a hotel toilet so my
room was on top no my room was on on top
right so I used that toilet and then
like Oh water came out so I went
downstairs to Gabriel ACS bathroom
what's going on I don't know man I think
that toilet broken man you go check the
coat check it out there's water
everywhere
yeah someone to go use the restroom and
it's oh how irresponsible I was not even
like offer to pay for the toilet or I
just say sorry and then Gabriel got
charged for it you think I can imagine
him going down one of my friend bought
the toilet sure the new fat-ass right
right you just sat down too hard just
like a relief like ah yeah and then was
that perfectly in the hole I must have
sat in a corner and I'm heavier now an
editorial broke the water disc shout out
how long were you on tour with a Gabriel
we were probably the beginning of my the
beginning of his stand-up career cuz I
was already well I was doing stand-up
already say 96 so I met him like in 98
and we were touring from 99 to 2003
you just met him at like an open mic or
well I was um I had a comedy room called
wild coyotes formerly tortillas formerly
Daily Planet
formerly got thumbs and formerly prime
could
same owner changed the name change the
menu change the staff change the prices
change the taxes Wow he changed the ETA
there every year every time we got tired
changed the name but he kept you know um
the comedy show started by some gay guy
named Ron Williams okay
but let me tell you about this guy no
wrong Williams he's a Filipino he gay
nothing nothing that everyone was gay
but he was very snarky you know he would
have put me up
mmm he was like the he was running
stand-up comedy in there like he started
commenting there not me not Jeff not
really he started that coming in there
throw the rookie you know was an open
mic I had to beg that's what I didn't
know that protocol like a shows booked
so I went over there and I a thing I
couldn't go up he's looked at me like
Starkey
nope like that nope
and I was there man I wanted to kick his
ass right I would I would III I don't
know why but I didn't want to punch him
in the face the way he said nope it's
okay sorry go ahead
so let's go he doesn't exist like a
backup singer Oh Gotham it would call
Gotham's and it was Wednesday night and
will tell you there was packed is that
played hell 200 there was 280 and
they're great if y'all fifty there was a
hundred you know so that plays hold 90
and there was 110 there was two packed
so they had karaoke after so this guy
was whack bro he wasn't whack this guy
would I'm host of the show from the DJ
booth oh that's lame I even go up in 4/4
uh yeah next up Jerry Russell from the
company store like it like a stripper DJ
like a strip club yeah so he had that
show they'd have to look after a while
um I tried going there and this other
comedian named Willie Barcena and Jeff
Garcia CH of course he had like he
started comedy with no 16 and he was uh
Nickelodeon's all that no nickel
audience
Jimmy Neutron oh she be notes you knew
Jimmy Neutron friend I don't know his
name but the other guy and he made money
off that show so that was his thing he
was young and the other game comedian
Willie
he was like doing colleges already he
was making money like my grand and
shorter college and here we had a period
to honor but the battle in the unit
didn't go anywhere so he was known but
not know like known so that those I
started hanging out there and
I started hanging around with Willie
Barcena and one thing led to another and
Jeff somehow he must was way in it to
run widows out out of the room like he
would have got him a friendly everybody
and Rob William was gone
and Gabriel came through that show
that's what for a while uh-huh
so uh was it I think um Jeff Garcia went
even when they went on a Sunday night to
get drunk and he did and he didn't know
that that was a gay night and then Ron
was there I guess so they were like a
fight or you know Rodney no punk man
might be gay but I stole the beat his
ass though right so that caused drama
there and they got rid of Jeff so there
Willie came in and me Willie Barcena we
ran that place for 11 years that's like
I booked the show I booked the shows and
he just um hosted and and got paid he
would he would get paid for hosting and
for booking a show even though I was
booking a show the budget for the comedy
was $200 enemy he kept a hundred so that
was his he get the hundred for being
there and not being there so he kept the
hundred even though he was not there
even years after he left I was still
running it he was talking a hundred you
you were like voluntarily yeah like just
I was getting free stage time every
Wednesday that's incredible man um but a
funny man I learned like comedy like
that comedian Jeff you will tell me a
Felipe hey Doc they're gonna they're
gonna I want you to sign for $75 and
give me 40 all right so I will give him
40 and I keep 35 so I didn't complain so
I just kept performing every Wednesday
and then that show moved to there are
two shows now Wednesday and Saturday so
Jeff turned into a fight with Ron and
they got rid of him so now I
well he had in 1998 on a seven every
glass that comes in with some crazy
looking cholo like like this guy wasn't
they caught him killer what they call a
[ __ ] oh no I was indignant cholo and I
like the guy he was cool with me yeah
you could probably smell your history on
like this guy knows I like the guy in he
walk talk to me like a dog like pretty
much try to intimidate me AVO me my
homie over here wants to do his comedy
game you want to know you give him a
little shot and say was your home yet
over there that fat [ __ ] all of the
heritage while you tie a bat [ __ ] if you
also spot he have to ask me himself
because he can't be taking you
everywhere so sooner or later he's gonna
have to speak up for himself
boom goes your ride homie your ride
homie so we're over there and talked to
him and he walked over to me like our 8
year old boy
hey me okay so I said sure bro you're
next late no the college put him up like
15 of em you know like a young comic
yeah you have dick jokes and he did like
voices and all his voices were dick
jokes this is my personai sheen of
Marlon the Martian having sex
he might monk you later you know this
guy from MTV those guys got the name on
the show their car to leave him behind
his BB the buff in having had I mean
give me some air you know what there are
sexual jokes mm-hmm
but out but people love product there
were nothing I was like that you know
they were there was only Pablo Francisco
and eros Pierce I guess I don't know you
I didn't know him at the time and they
were the only one they were doing like
noise this James and
James Anthony no J James Anthony the
third or James Evans at there was
another guy who did like voices and Luke
Torres
he probably the best one of all of them
besides Gabriel so check this out
he's because he got my friend right away
and I told him just follow me wherever I
go so we would go to places and perform
and I gotta play they didn't let him go
on because they don't know who he was
was a fat guy with bad teeth he like not
even 21 yet he was 20 and there was what
time um he was he wanted he never hosted
a show probably what I need someone to
host a show I can host it okay you gonna
host a whole show so he hosted a whole
show and they know we're all right
brothers what happened now that you're
gonna go over there and that managers
gonna give you a slip and it's gonna
stay $75 on it give me all of it so it's
my turn now uh-huh yeah a finder's fee
so I think you me all of it uh-huh so
then his [ __ ] ass is complaining bro I
never could what I never complained I
never to anybody what the deal was with
her money nobody knew so he went to go
tell Jeff right whoa that's ball they
can cry a little bit Jeff what is Jeff
gonna do bro he's 22 he's young he's
like 17 19 years old
Gabriel's age you know what's a pack
tiger are you [ __ ] don't get fat ass
no money he goes at least when I when I
have you sign I give you 435 you keep 40
and I said really right now go call him
over here so the three of us and I said
man besides me who else have let you
host or put your shows
who else me who has given you money no
one right bro I give you I you got a
free lesson in stand-up comedy of
hosting you got to perform for
our got to go try new jokes no one is
gonna give you that don't you ever cry
about money ever in your life it's a
great lesson for all come ever cry about
how much you guys are nothing at this
cuz you're gonna make money in the
future he made at least me a little bit
yeah so he was always business minded I
guess from the jump he was always well
he had a job no one else had a job oh
okay yeah he had a job at though of work
like a kiosk selling t mobile phones or
Verizon phones or singular for whatever
yeah but he's in like the 1% of comedy
now like he's I mean he's he's like cut
top 7 right it's incredible like just
just the Empire he's been able to build
yeah man and like what do you is is that
something you saw in him early on is
like there's something about him or what
do you attribute to that and you've been
on the road with him whoa like what did
you learn the impersonations and all
that okay we like that yeah but we ended
up opening I ended up on working with
him and he got on a show Nickelodeon all
that mm-hmm
and I learned a show called K locals in
1998 and I was on 99 episodes
and I hope tonight and I was a warm-up
act for that show okay cool so whenever
a comedian didn't prove they didn't do
well or didn't show up I was the one I
was feeling the spot okay but me and
Gabriel were booking the show people
don't know that it was Roger Paul Mike
Robles but Roger Paul only knows New
York comics and they were not gonna fly
no new york comics too early so I booked
the whole show with Alec Comics I'm the
one who got dummy rare on the show
really use the plug I got people on that
show that would have never been on any
other show like what time I saw Tommy
where I he said I'm how could it get on
these banning shows I mean my I could
just my name it I could just change my
name to Herrera mm-hmm so I I allowed I
can't show the show and I'm gonna show
you know this guy's a tastemaker here
likes to book that show bro like I had
to book that show and I was good at it
like I knew I was always good at placing
people because I have to work a security
job watching stuff and then one day I'm
I am I got the job as a dispatcher I was
saving that company money and overtime
because I was like something like a
Camino uh security guard is there for
more than eight hours or is there for 12
you know pay him double and time and a
half so I will tell that guy that that
security guard I want you to wait there
for another two hours or four hours an
extra four hours so I'll keep him for 12
hours and then I have the other guy come
in four hours early so I cover the [ __ ]
I cover the 24 hours [ __ ] was two people
they both were 12 you should be like a
manager or you should be an agent or so
there was no one else to go there that
couldn't find nobody
I would log on to my job put on my
uniform and go there to someone shows up
are there any other big mistakes you
know comics make early on that good cuz
like him complaining about money and
it's really like when you're starting
out and I mean even now I'm a little
Vern ein years into the game let's go
play because he didn't get anything
Oh gaining money but it's like a lot of
a lot of comic especially now they see
the internet and they're like oh I just
want to blow up it's like we'll get good
first then like just be grateful for
each other later like there's a comic
who emailed me on for San Antonio a
common female comic and I never get to
the giver whatever I'll just give you
one advice so never worry about the
money
yeah cuz you'll never get anywhere mmm
if you worry about the money you never
have fun you never successful and she
was born able all what are you telling
me that cuz you make money so I
shouldn't be worried about the money and
she was sad face so I don't wanna
explain it to her stupid ass that time
I just sent her a quote again now she
could take that core and welcome to
other communities this what Philippa
told me I was gonna tell her yeah he's
right stupid yeah you're understand how
people say they're funny but they the
only fun in their hometown I have a
friend named Mikey oh and he from
Chicago he works every the biggest
Latino shows ever even Latin comedy
shows
he's got peace cash and he pays you
before the show all of it before the
show I love those $800 when he drives up
the air at the hotel he go here's a
money man I might not be around at the
end of the show here's a money he was
don't bring it with you leave it here he
goes there's too many people here I know
you have money now so I was cool so he
was telling I was asking about this
commie what's up it's coming
you think it could come you only retire
him he has a Chicago funny 30 I said
what does that mean
you lost 30 money 20 minutes all in fun
in Chicago once he leaves Chicago he's
back to ten minutes mm-hmm I've seen
several comics like that here in Atlanta
and touring around to every street
reference every enough about Henry Welch
the dangerous man in comedy I love that
guy's manicotti that guy is so funny
don't care man if it was two carbons and
a wrapper he almost came on here back in
the day and then he kind of kind of
shied away from it some people just
don't wanna talk but a lot of people
like you have to baby step them and tell
of what this is and how important today
to do any podcast mm-hmm because people
listen remember that a hundred or twenty
lost whether you're gonna remember you
yeah and a lot of the urban comics
another younger like the older Latino
comics I have no idea what a podcast is
because I wipe the pocket of the
podcasting is still like an American
thing and a lot of laughs I like a lot
of people don't even don't even know
like my fans
I tend to loose my podcast
what page is that on or I really got to
tell them listen man I have a radio show
they don't it it's called the worse or
full podcast itself [ __ ] looking for
podcasts mmm they look for what's awful
so I can't explain to them what a
podcast was a head farmers internet
radio but your if your fans are so
engaged like you you have like a loyal
fan base that like you say something and
they respond like that's I mean yeah
that could be the goal should be the
goal like every comedian that's one
thing I learned you know early on from
when I was you know Willie Barcena and
we met out I did I met him briefly um
what's-his-name out Harold Williams okay
from the heartland Harley will yeah yeah
yeah yeah and my friend told me I'll bro
that that guy right there and then he
pointed at Kevin James to they were
before they were famous uh-huh you love
Kevin James bro he's like a major star
our colleges like he was doing all the
colleges and so Harlan Williams
and also so um Dane Cook was an was like
another guy that will eat all that guy
didn't cook my all ecologies yeah but
then cook did something that like mean
we're not doing you know he was doing
this before there was an Instagram
before them the social media before
there was MySpace think could was show
to these colleges with a paper that read
name phone no name email what you like
about the show I said I thought I paper
mm-hmm and he called here like all
everyone emails so whenever you come to
a town he'll email everybody bloomed
whether 500 night 10 or whatever
by the time myspace started he was the
first kind of 1 million because he was
doing it the heart a little stuff that
no one else does so when I thought when
I one last comment standing I bought it
like like I have a website a website and
I bought out
about this app where you could just
login to my website like dreamer a man
from join my website so I had I had a
one of the comments hanging on our side
and walking around like any people into
my web page mmm and I'm some of the
people who are storm away I have their
emails and I sell him a little
newsletter remind him I'll turn around I
don't gonna do that much and you I don't
gonna do that anymore I don't do it
anymore but um I hate to do it yeah and
I each others to like an older comic
anybody was like over 50
they have no idea bro [ __ ] that hey
that's not hey how many Murphy did it
that's not how Richard Pryor did it they
did it their way
but those comics and they had your
attitude right now
they were never made boom exactly I'm
sorry had your attitude right now and
your talent you'll quit he was your
[ __ ] quit Richard Pryor would have
quit if he had to do an Instagram yeah
those guys never had Instagram people
didn't have to because there they were
stars it was there was nothing in the ad
when they were on Tonight Show 18
million people saw you do tonight's show
now you look you've 6e it or two or
you'll be better off if they watch what
Hulu
yeah those those shows now are more just
like to have a good clip to send the
Booker's and that's it but nobody
watches it when I show you then it'll
get famous you're gonna get famous three
ways if you're interesting you're a big
personality so that helps a lot of your
big personality and you're funny you're
gonna be a star because a lot of people
say man if I just get on Joe Rogan
that's it
no that ain't gonna be it if you're not
a talker like me I'm talking right on
his podcast now if I'm waiting for him
for the for the host right here to ask
me another question and then I just give
him a lame answer or a short answer how
far we're gonna get we're gonna go
through this podcast in to one hour and
we're gonna get nothing out of it so you
don't talk if you have a problem
speaking in public to people after a
show if you have a problem hanging out
Joe Rogan podcast Marc Maron
your mom's house none of those are gonna
help you cuz you don't got it mm-hmm
you don't have the it factor you know a
lot of people don't have the edge factor
who still becomes popular because they
do other stuff you know they they write
a screenplay they do something else to
how your career a company stand-up
comedy now in 2019 you can just quote
JFK ask not what comedy can do for you
but what can you could do for comedy
like now ask what the country could do
for you and what the world you could do
for the country the country is already
here
mmm-hmm comedy is already here bro
booming what can you do you know what
are you gonna bring different woo just
mic drop on that one for real yeah
that's facts yeah all right there's some
comics out there who are like who are
like the norm you know like Jerrod
Carmichael probably don't have an
Instagram or a Twitter right Facebook
yeah but you know drawed Carmichael he
has the joy when you hear that you want
Carmichael show when he had a Twitter
then he got rid of it right he never had
it you never used the I don't think he's
ever see you he's an exception okay I
know you're gonna think how about this
guy he's an exception that guy writes
every day he made the right connections
and you didn't what was the third you
said the three ways a comic can get
famous she said be interesting have a
big personality and what's the third and
think you said there's gonna be there
were three hotel night be nice to
everyone
boom gratitude bro okay like like like
Jim Leyland from [ __ ] the Trailer
Park Boys you know when you're gone and
left people never remember how funny you
were died remember the
- you had you know like how do you know
what like me like I would like stay at
the Laugh Factory and now go up there as
he Paul Rodriguez and I say why in a
minute he's mexican-american how am I
gonna get to know him so I went to after
bartender I say well what are this guy
drink he drinks Irish whiskey
um Irish whiskey and that was coffee he
was yeah okay so he came me and bro and
he sat down and I went to I don't drink
so I got my drink ticket and I think him
Ian Irish whiskey and he got two bucks a
tip and now I went to Paul Rodriguez and
it was so much a part of genius
I got who's your drink and he said
thanks and and he said sit down
first I thought with him man he'd have
his drink and he's talking [ __ ] about
the comedian on stage with yeah yeah he
tell you what this CoverGirl's day you
know what you know what he's been doing
those jobs for 20 years now and then he
followed the comedian I was making go
doing penis jokes and then but they were
not funny like he would not deliver them
right I guess
and then I'm parle-g goes up there a man
if you're gonna do take jokes have the
balls to say say it
commit don't try to clean it up that's
true advice okay like you personally
saying if you're gonna be a dirty comic
just be a turkey carving don't worry
about I'm gonna be next I'm not gonna be
clean next you have to be clean no you
don't if you're if you're a dirty comic
and you have a a nice personality you'll
go for Joe Diaz have never done a clean
set in his life in his life in life and
everyone said I was on stage and all the
bombing he was [ __ ] I gotta get the
convenience to laugh at least so I went
upstairs man I'm sweating around here
like Joe Diaz showcasing for Nickelodeon
fool the crowd laughs Joe Diaz goes up a
stage he's having a hard time - I'm
sweating up here like Felipe Esparza
trying out a new joke in front of Karla
Mencia hilarious oh my gosh dude were
you uh were you cool with Carlos Mencia
I never met him
oh never him okay I never had a
conversation with him it was like
passing by I don't know him at all
okay I know of him I know he does time
in between comics but that's it mm-hmm
and what you were talking about bombing
always get comments to share they're
like worst bomb like getting booed or
something thrown at them booing car
bombing happens like in a lot in the
beginning of your career because you
don't know how to use all your weapons
like you're a Jedi but you know you
don't know how to how to swing your
lightsaber how to work your mind how to
pick up shades that stuff you learned on
the way like I still bomb but it's not
like a bomb physically where everybody
goes man die [ __ ] bomb but I
know I'm bombing mmm
inside I feel it if I have to go to my a
joke that I did have my first special
I'm bombing I don't know what I started
could I have a set that I'm doing on
them I left lakes in October and I
really know it by memory I know how to
begin with it I know how to uh whatever
right but I started like the crowd 9
into that [ __ ] and then I felt like a
hack doing it cuz I already know these
drugs but they were getting laughs but
then I switch back to my other stuff but
the real bombing I've had where it was
ugly was it that place water yo T's okay
and I were bombing bro like I have my
notes and then I'm that guy Willie
Barcena he was like a bully you know
like a comedy bully like you meet him
everywhere
like the kind of guy that out of Europe
on stage and then when you get off he
sees your set list he rips it to rid of
these jobs talk but it's true you didn't
get rid of them you know they really
suck but anyway so I'm barmy bro like
like I could feel that though my back
sweaty like it was all sweaty and my
five minutes turn into in front of an
hour you know I went through 20 minutes
of material in two minutes I've been
there for sure my mouth gets dry bro and
I'm bombing them and I'm bombing I don't
know how to get off that's a part of a
bombing you don't know how to get off
and Willie Barcena goes up there like
he's my dad and he hugs me on my
shoulder and he had collected like had
me the mic so I give the microphone he
wants me like alpha stage like hugging
me come on cross dying yeah hurry sir it
hurts bro meristem are you up there yes
wait a little arm mm-hmm yeah he goes up
there give it up for Philippe give it up
for Philippe man he tried he goes he
tried man that's how you could say he
try but he failed killer bad for failing
people he bombed up here man I mean
nothing worked
you're getting laughs making fun of me
um and he was getting big laughs I don't
he angry I should [ __ ] this fool up
right but he would say man he's not he's
Mexican man you people are Mexican he's
shown no love you should you
that's what problem man we never stick
together just you laughs even if he said
knock-knock jokes
Ryan across laughing right and I learned
from that mister I didn't learn that
bombing right
okay I'm stupid you know I should have
learned from that Bobby but I just hurt
so much and I don't know if you don't
ever bomb a bombing can last three days
Oh
mommy no laughs you go up again
i'ma get you my quit yeah yeah I was
just about to say that it lasts until
the next show and hopefully you can
rebound this they broke I bomb on
chocolate sundae oh yeah Bob Harvey had
the bomb there but I've done the show
yeah and now what's the name mom
Katie what's the name TK Kirkland T to
the [ __ ] clerking on here yeah
he's a fool yeah he was his hit a
homeboy with him right and homeboy like
an old comic not even a comment was made
it worse she were happening young
brother you up there too long I'm like
10 minutes I didn't run the light
afterwards the bombing run your light do
you like this we'll get him you just
keep so he goes you just up there too
long and then TK Kirkland told me you're
funny but he was either I know your
audience or whatever right she said
something like thank you he said a
little bit Bobby podcast a little bit
advice I forgot what he said but he
little being a good guy because they
don't run the future he got me on two
shows hmm where I got Pina
you got men on Nick Kevin Hart show he
was hosting he got me another show that
um G be smooth with hosting so he's a
good guy I mean he knows so he got me
but I bombed so hard I had to redeem
myself
I said I can walk around with his egg in
my face so I looked around and he'll bro
where's the next urban show there
tomorrow he was all scruncho he has that
show at the Hollywood Park Casino or
they I'm going there whatever the show
you know 9:00 but they don't start that
[ __ ] till 10:00
of course first I'll get there 9:00 all
right and I wait where everyone gets in
so I watch you I get there the arm you
are a bomb I really are Neal I bomb so
Philippe you had a rough night last
night
and there you go all right so did that
show bounce back and then I'm gonna come
here name Eric Blake so I did the same
jokes I did it I didn't suddenly but I
slowed it down you know I was a nervous
out of the nervous and I killed and then
a lot of urban comics there gave me like
a lot of advice I think I Eric Blake and
scruncho stop s scruncho told me that
I'm an Eric Blake he said listen man
when you do a urban audience if you have
a long story
trying to see if something silly on the
way to a story could be more [ __ ] lose
your ass so I have a job where I stayed
that I'm sneaking this girl into my
house to have sex with her in my bedroom
my parents are at home everybody's home
my brother sleep in the top bunk bed so
man you gotta do the whole story bro so
I went up on stage and I see like this
so I'm sticking it to at my house so I
saw this girl walk over my dad so it's
walk over my dad a little tags along the
way the walk right right right yeah then
I threw it I started making love to like
a prison inmate I added that I covered
her mouth kept her mouth shut so that
that's what I learned details but that
then you know that bar I bombed there
but I bombed the hardest problems Tacoma
Washington mm-hmm
though the headliner yeah and it was a
bad bad deal it was um I was two shows I
did a show a first show I put the put
against $700 okay for two Niners one
night in Hawaii and one night to coma so
they float they got me a plane ticket
and I flew out to Hawaii and the night
before so a night before I got to see
Hawaii for the first time I met some
Asian women and cute took a photo over
there I never know why I hate
I was go to the show bro it was like no
lie bro 17 people there that play host
like 200 and the promoter was sitting in
the front with a broken leg so every job
every time I work Generosa would look at
anyway I did the whole 45 bro no laughs
then I went to my room kill myself so
the next day I'm waiting for further to
take me to the airport
mmm-hmm and the team they take me to the
airport late because they were smoking
weed and a pair of small weed I was
smoking weed back then so I miss my
flight
Hawaiian flights oh I talk to and then I
talk to the promoter man you your homie
dropped me off too late you know I miss
my flight
you know man talk to them and tell your
mom is dying time you getting married
lie to them at the promoter saying damn
ball
so I usually I use the money that they
gave me have to buy another ticket to
get to I think California at least so I
can California major California then are
you 200 my money to get to do coma and
if they were gonna reimburse me into
coma so when I get to Tacoma
I guess it's tradition I guess his
mother invited me to eat I never been to
no foul urban home you know no
african-american house so I'm with my
hat I sit down she was all you know say
hi nobody mmm your buddy me woman yeah
I've never used so I sat down she goes
it's you where we take hats off at their
house I took my hat off
and they made me some fried chicken and
macaroni and cheese chicken was
delicious the macaroon she was like the
last part so it's to her at the mode of
the pan on
you know the time all right that was my
my people round
oh yeah the crest so I was a casino like
nearby where I'll stain I'm gonna cross
the street so I went over there and
started gambling playing blackjack and I
won like 980 bucks and they pick me over
to a show I went to the show let me tell
you something for anybody out there that
the headliner or you're gonna headline a
show or somebody calls you up and to ask
you I want you to head like my room
before you even agree to the headlining
spot you ask him how many comedians are
gonna go up before me who I can I bring
an opener who else is gonna go up what
is this show gonna be like it might
gonna be one comedian or a host and I go
up so I just said yes you know I said
yes I never I didn't ask no other
questions just before last comics - I'm
at the Tacoma Washington and the whole
world goes up before me they bring up
the rapper Oh what the chef of the place
goes up and tell and shows the plate of
the specials he'd like this some dumb
whack-ass [ __ ] does a def jam wrap that
sucks I hate poetry first of all I poor
she read I'll let you read it I don't
like to be read by people with attitude
you know so um so this comedian goes up
bombs mm I stated comedian kills but
this guy one of those guys that has like
a funny
he's on Tacoma 20 right his shade was
only funny in Tacoma I swear to God but
all his references was killing now y'all
remember jr. from the barbershop
remember when he broke his leg they were
running around the room laughing and
then then the Barbara Barbara was there
bro oh my laughs you know high-five
so after that thunder bro I love the
child to our Phillippe it so he could
hear a taco drop you can hear a croc
taco grudge and I go up there bro in
hmmm I say a joke and some guys heckling
me but then he goes up on stage and
we're having a rose petal on stage bro
right and I said and I looked at and I
looked at him and the audience Chris
Rock was right there's black people and
then there's all you guys so the crowd
exploded bro oh they liked it they liked
it only laughs oh my gosh and I said
thank you good night after that it could
have gone either way there I said thank
you good night did you do the full hour
no okay cuz they were heckling and
yelling all rude and a guy wouldn't get
up on stage and I said well you try it
and I went up a state you [ __ ] suck
dick Oh heckling him okay so then I just
left a table to my room so I went over
there I was about to drink some tequila
and forget about my sobriety I watched
PBS I think friends and our children
here just died or they're playing French
I'm not sure that's live right that's
what people say right you're riding high
in April shot down at me uh-huh but I
don't play that tune when I'm back on
top in June you know life is up ups and
downs yeah so I have my $900 still so I
didn't give a [ __ ] they pay me right
they're not right so I let him to the
airport but we haven't got paid for both
shows and plus
for the flight telling to the promoter
on the phone he did Owyhee
and say man am I waiting for hearing
wife she hadn't give me my money
oh she's driving to the airport right
now she's gonna bring it to you the
airport
she's just to get to my hotel room like
you said she wasn't do it last night so
waiting at the airport I'm betting I'm
getting close to the gate I have like 25
minutes before they start boarding and
I'm thinking should I miss my flight and
wait for my money so I said [ __ ] this so
I went car my flight and I never got and
I called him up a man she never showed
up a flight all right she were waiting
for you
but our and then I go I told my friend
the guy who booked me hey man your
friend never paid me oh man he did that
[ __ ] again
Oh what kind of friend books you on a
one Dexter by the way oh okay good
company I do have an exact one Dexter so
so think about this lesson learn people
someone's booking you and it's gonna be
out of town as for deposit even even if
you're a young comic like our host I
don't know it doesn't hurt that guy
offers you five hundred dollars can you
send me two hundred first I can't I
can't do the show you're not losing $500
you never had you never you never had
the final dollar to begin with I mean
yeah so that was my thing from now on
asking for at least half because if the
show gets canceled at least I get money
and I learned lesson learned people I
don't give a [ __ ] if you've been doing
comedy two years once somebody offers
you money just say they ask you how much
you want to get paid see that's a trick
question from that guy cuz always ask
for more than you want say you only want
to get paid two hundred after guy for
six hundred and work your way down to
the what you want you're never going to
work your way up
hmm ever ever yes for five hundred he
goes alright here you go
gate and they're gonna get it and
they're gonna get it ask for the
exaggerated amount always especially
they don't have an agent just say oh man
we could only pay a 500 ok just this
gate and computer room is there gonna be
a green room there it's gonna be a hotel
for us before you could stay at well
there's no hotel you could just try back
all right we have 700 then we need gas
money
we need food if you can't do the none of
those things for you don't work with
that guy you know you're not gonna lose
no friend you know you're gonna be
better off in you're gonna save yourself
a big headache what's the balance
between getting that stage time verse
getting the money especially as you're
developing as a comedian well if nobody
is offering you any gigs
just keep doing stand-up comedy just
wherever whenever yeah okay but if you
want to make money and stand up I would
say go to a restaurant or a bar that has
the hottest Friday Saturday Sunday like
that place is packed Friday Saturday and
Sunday I'm pretty sure is whack on
Wednesdays mmm week on Tuesdays so you
tell the owner listen man how would we
do a Tuesday two-for-one college comedy
night $10 two-for-one and you tell the
owner um I'll keep the door and I'll
split the door with you or whatever
whatever he agrees on and then you just
make a little bit of money but always
make sure that even if you're a young
comic try to make $50 and knees for show
mean a lot but $50 is gas bro it's gas
it's a meal you need it and you get 10
shows a month for $50 that's 500 bucks
you know you're gonna figure it like
this I thought I figured out my rent my
rent was $800 my phone bill was a
hundred my food was what for the whole
month for the whole month 102 I guess so
you figure I gotta make it I gotta make
$1,100 a month
all right now for your own comments are
trying to book yourself for comedy shows
and you need the money for next month
you can just forget about getting booked
for next month ain't gonna happen
it's not gonna happen so no [ __ ] right
now we're right now is July right it was
June June 29 to 28 so July is already
here you could just forget about getting
booked for July trying to get booked for
November see trying to book your way
ahead of time so you're not too worried
about December if you could book
December right now it's a bunch of shows
you're gonna be good bro and then you
work you don't worry about the summer no
more now you worry about November you
get November filled up you got October
now you got Augie you got September you
get August
you got July but the rest of the fall is
booked so July you find a job you know
August you open for somebody or whatever
but you try to book yourself like just a
guy that booking a show for an open for
July are worried booked up
okay Matt how bout uh September see I'm
pretty sure the last one though they
have September booked mm-hmm what are
some ways you recommend getting booked
on these shows I will find out like if
there's a headliner coming into town
anyway smoke weed show up and bring that
for a fat sack okay or offer to drive
him all week be nice get in will you get
when you can get in like like that's me
like with a young car with that comment
Willie I just drive him bro like he
didn't he was an alcoholic so I would
just drive his car I would go to his
house park my car and I would drive him
around everywhere trying to be friends
with somebody that's making it you know
somebody is successful or start up or
start a podcast or the best way I would
say is this like there's a comedy club
like bonkers or or a punchline you find
out who's booking the show and asked a
man
hey bro how about we have a bonkers
podcast what do you mean bonkers podcast
well you had like when you get the
headliners that come in maybe they could
come in a day early
and we'll promote the show in my podcast
cuz I people think that they think too
big like oh I'm never gonna be like Joe
Rogan you're right
you never may be like he started his
podcast when podcast first came out yeah
he's at eleven fifteen hundred episodes
forget about it mm-hmm but you could do
is be the hottest local podcast was
winner which between a seven-mile area
of your neighborhood like if you could
be the hottest podcast in Atlanta just
didn't just in Buckhead think about it
there's no other podcast in this town
you could be the only one and you saw
adds to the local businesses yeah now
you can walk up to a mall and pause and
offer my own partisan Martin Paul I have
one hug
five hundred subscribers within five
miles of your restaurant give me $200 a
month and I'm a promoting show every
[ __ ] podcast that is cheap
advertisement bro mmm-hmm and I that's
how we did it our first our first ad was
a was a la la Florida de la reina bakery
I told that guy give me 500 bucks and I
promote your podcast for two months two
months it's very generous yeah so we did
it and we told people and he was our
first guy and then later on we we got
Pitt we had a we had a guest from that
show I'm dying up here on Showtime right
yeah those that were promoting people so
they found out that I were a comedy
podcast they paid us $1500 to interview
him we would have interviewed that
person for free right we're trying to
get a hold of him and keep canceling
so they made him come to our podcast and
they paid us he didn't get paid a dime
you know well see you just gotta stick
around man okay my friend Willie Barcena
he has Jay Leno once which one of your
friends didn't make it the ones who quit
cuz I don't care if you're doing comedy
for 25 years if you're a nice guy
sooner or later someone just take you
under his wing like me when I was
struggling even after like I got into an
argument with fluffy and we stopped
talking and I start working with him
other comedians like me like Angela
Johnson I got Angela Johnson Cheryl
Sherri Shepherd I'm not sure Shepherd
yeah Sherri Shepherd from the view like
what time I walked up to her and then I
told her how you been how you been
it was not good mmm and she asked me you
need money
it was any help I was talking to mrs.
she's a millionaire bro like she's been
on the view and she offered like I had
offered me like assistance and I said no
I'm good you know I'm good but I thought
was so sweetest thing ever
I've heard Russell Peters does that a
lot - yeah he likes to support and help
out man I opened up for him man he gave
me the most money ever got for three
shoulders and then I go when he gave me
the money with all cash I say who I
gotta kill look at a push so coy oh yes
yes who you tell me but very generous he
bought me a watch and even a young comic
like the comedian Willie like he would
pay for our meals mm-hmm Gabriel s have
always paid for our meals and if you're
a comic man is it on for young comics if
you have a girlfriend and you want to do
stand-up comedy don't take trips don't
go to Hawaii
no go to New York with her don't go
anywhere with that relationship that
nothing to do a stand-up comedy you know
it's tough you love her
but you know what man if you really
loves to like
it's like when gee it's like being a
stand-up comic
it's like Peter disciple of Jesus Christ
you gotta leave everything behind and
follow me and enjoy the riches and
believe believe bro you're gonna work
out you're gonna believe in yourself
because in the end you're the only one I
believe is gonna believe in yourself hmm
and be happy
you gotta be happy bro you gotta be
happy to do this like I'm running to the
airport I saw um Chelsea Handler mm-hmm
and I know I don't know the woman I mean
when she was carving at The Comedy Store
she was just some woman that I would
white girl that passes by she's a
comedian all right and I said hello to
her I just said the first thing that
came to my mind I'll uh I just waved hi
she was passing by my seed and I said I
love your interview on Howard Stern one
of the you're so honest and then she
said thank you but uh if you look at
Chelsea's matter the interview if you
ever looked for it of Howard Stern the
first one and it really like resonate to
me you know like um her struggle and
what she came from like she was like the
first person in her family to have a
checkbook
whoa I mean she was talking bad about
our family you know like they're not
they were not into it like they were
like pretty much lame and I remember
helping my mom with her checkbook you
know what i doing she was doing all the
stuff that I immigrant kid does for
their family did you translate
everything yeah her family was I guess
not into anything so she was - she was
working supporting their men taking
everyone else to dental appointments and
all that whatever she was doing she was
running a household as a child
mm-hmm and I thought that was very
impressed have you know that's why she
pretty
she work she's that because she'd know
how to manage stuff a lot of comedians
come into comedy without knowing how to
manage stuff like no skills like I would
say that even the comedian the one I
started off with
this guy had in 12 tonight shows bro
with Jay Leno but he doesn't work social
media he doesn't know how to use
Instagram he doesn't know how to use
none of that but if that guy would have
been the first to do it you know I mean
yeah that's what I would think cook you
gotta know the latest like if you want
to learn what's new just listen to
Howard Stern I mean you know so Howard
Stern or any like any podcast that's
relevant like Joe Rogan or Marc Maron
you can you you're gonna know about the
ladies can choose what to get learn from
other car learn from successful comments
like Kevin Harlan what did he do every
day he gets up every morning he gets on
a treadmill it works out weights he does
five hours of interviews and there's a
lot of comics who can't do any of you
like they go to radio and they later
they let the radio guy do all the
talking and they leave the radio station
without mentioning the show without
mentioning whatever advice for any
comedian if the Kimmy if the first of
all when you get to the realization they
don't know who you are okay they have a
list or your comedian and you been on
there they're reading off your Wikipedia
or your resume as you get there mm-hmm
this is what you do we have well
Felipe's that's right Philippe responds
out here and I'm going with the purse
line this week you say your name and you
say we're gonna be at mmm if you don't
like the way the conversations going
just every time they go to you Felipe
Esparza at the punchline I learned that
from Margaret Shaw nice how do the
interview with Gabriel s to promote his
shorter punchline and Margaret Shaw
Toxie comes in how you guys doing
Margaret Schaal beat the Wilbur theater
with the Warfield dinner in a class two
shows how you baron Margaret so I've
been great I'm gonna be at the Wolford
theater in o'clock Arkansas eight
o'clock and she didn't say [ __ ] just put
that but but her interview I've seen
these two comedians do Mancow
mm-hmm and Manco probably insult to the
community you wear makeup and then he
just stood quiet like no no interview is
gonna go your way you get up making your
way goes back to your saying one of the
best ways to make it is to have a big
personality yeah be outgoing you can't
be lame man yeah or if you don't know
how to interview go check out our go-to
app and go how do I try any of you
better make good answers I could I tell
you what do you like about school lunch
don't ever answer a question like that
what you answer a question like there so
the listener can know what question you
answer what I like about lunch first of
all is lunch
I like burritos I hate standing in line
you know I hate what I lose my my meal
ticket mm-hmm details bro details
I hate when you would ask a personal
question and going yeah
[ __ ] that dude I wanna punch him in the
[ __ ] face dude if I don't get a long
answer from you you better get the [ __ ]
at the podcast yep I hate when I had to
do all the talking because people are
lame
they're [ __ ] shy I hate it bro I hate
whenever I do a podcast from our
publicist and we have a young person who
doesn't know how to do any of use so you
have a new album come out yeah okay fat
ass where is it coming on it and another
thing also if you're gonna be a guest on
a podcast as soon as you get off the
podcast go tell people you're on that
podcast
mmm if you're begging to be on a podcast
one thing I hate the most is you beg to
be on my podcast and then when I posted
you're gonna be on my partner with a
photo and you don't need to eat it I
gotta do the podcast with this guy right
here oh and I kept going after that
comment but we're gonna put the [ __ ]
podcast up and he never even put in his
[ __ ] page why it's wrong Felipe
sparsa you're nobody I know who you are
that's why I said yeah no one and I kept
asking and we're gonna put the podcast
up we're gonna put bro I took time to do
your podcast you never put it up I want
to kill him bro
I worked in my time on your lame podcast
you didn't put it up [ __ ] that
[ __ ] bro well we're putting this
on Willie Barcena kicked his ass I was
happy a word but the guy started off
with he's crazy now bro
now he's crazy bro I assumed it was back
then found out that that comedian was
doing his joke and he was on his way to
Vegas from Corpus he made a u-turn and
went to help [ __ ] and went to a
restaurant and try to kick his ass
what'd you get bro for not posting that
podcast and how you can have a podcast
and not posted on your page and put your
lame comedy there I don't know this was
going up there I promise I don't want to
get killed what was the real quick what
was the fluffy situation what were you
guys arguing about was it business or
what business broker you just say just
say um are the opener were gaining $200
for the week
all right just say for example okay
we're not getting that much okay way
more than that okay I was like wait what
but this fool are laying bro okay and he
half of his act is about about me right
so with the imitating me to write and
doing my new and Sons and kind of doing
my job too so I said listen man you
gotta give me 24 25 more dollars and
he's unfunny [ __ ] but I didn't
say no else cuz there's no else I'm done
you know so he couldn't do it so I did
the next best thing
what are you doing when you're not happy
at a job you start [ __ ] up so I
started getting drunk
deliverance talking [ __ ] to him he goes
oh [ __ ]
whack-ass you up there doing the same
[ __ ] you know just talking [ __ ]
about getting his ear being annoying bro
like to the point where I'm gonna get
rid of this guy i'ma beat his ass mm-hmm
I was just not happy anymore
and well and I don't care if anybody
knows this I'll tell you right now when
we were open whenever we would do like a
theater where the majority was 90
percent Mexican I would only do five
minutes on stage well no we're not
audiences are white I would do 35 and
although the guy would do five so I'm
doing although I'm doing all the time
man we're in Cleveland Indiana and I did
35 destroy that [ __ ] and he'll have to
do an hour
he kills two but every little San Jose
you're gonna do five minutes I said why
I can't just do 30 are you afraid of
follow that [ __ ] I said that bro you've
read that about 25 bucks
hey listen man I'll do five minutes if
you admit to me are you afraid of follow
me and he just walked away
are you gonna be like that he just
walked away like a fat lip fat punk a
little [ __ ] right maybe I'm still mad
that's what the whole 75 yeah this thing
if it routed back I became lame I
started getting loaded and drunk and
doing cocaine and being a burden to
everybody and then it got rid of me mmm
ya know no harm done no harm done and um
we don't get along but that's fine man
you know the Beatles don't talk no more
bro you know nobody nobody was meant to
get along you know you know you grow out
of people you know you move on I don't
know how long we're gonna be friends but
but where you move on you grow out of
people nothing wrong with that and I
don't hate the guy and he was like very
our instrumental in the beginning of my
career and so advising him you know but
you move on you grow you get better
well we've grown a lot from this
interview man I appreciate you so much
for taking the time to do this is uh
before we get out of here is there
anything else you want the world to know
yeah we have a podcast I mean with repo
Torres it's called a what's off fool
podcast sometimes Johnny shows up and
I'm gonna have a show on Netflix called
gente five gentrified and I play a guy
named crazy Dave I'm in three episodes
there's ten episodes or three
Tanna bad it was a full season I
probably had more episodes but yeah and
I'm I was special on Netflix also I want
to tell you the comments and if you're a
common listening him you've been doing
comedy for 10 years and you're funny and
you want a half-hour special or you want
a one-hour special do it yourself now
man I mean if you're not planning to
move to move to California and if you're
not planning to move to New York or
Chicago or San Francisco or Texas I
would say do your own special you know
wait
I would say like wait till you ask to a
feature for a comment that's gonna sell
out and then recorded that there my
first special I recorded at the Denver
Denver Comedy Works I put my camcorder
did 25 minutes I made a bunch of DVDs
and so alone for 10 bucks each mmm
shitty comedy still had the Memorex on
it right there just bootleg a bootleg
yeah yeah and my I was waiting for
Netflix special two years ago like
someone or a Comedy Central special
never came so my wife and I we saved up
money and we shot it ourselves
and my agent sold it for a big profit to
UM to HBO just say we paid $25 for a we
saw over five bucks that's how good it
was yeah and your wife's your manager
yeah that's it's good enough that team
yeah so now you know like a lot of you
have a you have a cell phone man you
have more technology than the then the
first astronaut I went to the moon
you could really you can recall your own
special on a phone mmm just started to
your fans or give it to your fans
and just promote yourself I have a
bumper sticker have anything but
anything with your name on it I have
something for them to take you know a
sticker
hey man follow me back mm-hmm gold yeah
man all right all right hot breath
averse you just heard it from the man
himself your pocketbook all how breath I
thought it was before carbonate we have
stinky breath
no it's for hot has hot inside like you
do man and based on your experience
would you mind just looking in the
camera let them know who you are and why
they should listen to hot breath
what's up fool Felipe Esparza I'm on hot
breath podcast you should into the hot
breath podcast feeling some of the OPA
answer so many questions and it's
podcast very instrumental for any young
comic or even an older comic and also
very entertaining to hear the stories or
insights on people yes I appreciate so
much hayleybay Esparza thanks for being
on her breath it was our 15 rolling yeah
thanks
[Music]
[Music]
I breath